I get that holiday parties are in full
swing and if you're hosting one this
year the Cheesecake Factory has some fun
ideas on what to serve guests Don
Barrett and Michael Bach from Cheesecake
Factory join us today with a beautiful
spread and a unique idea we're talking
about street corn yes yes we are thank
you yeah thank you so uh Kendall you
know Cheesecake Factory is known for
having over 250 menu items that are made
from scratch in our restaurants every
single day but today we bought our
classic Bourbon and honey and we're
going to give you a modified version of
our Mexican street corn which is going
to be fun and easy for your holiday
party so this is something people could
order and take home and serve to their
guests you can and it's also simple and
easy to make for home too so Michael you
ready to get started yes so very simple
at home if you have a your barbecue in
the backyard little medium high heat you
want to start off with a corn cob a few
minutes and then I kind of lined it up
here to where you're gonna cut it in
half then in half again half again so
you end up with eight pieces with one
corn on the cob brush on the mayonnaise
so you would take your pieces like this
brush on the mayonnaise like that then
you have your parmesan and then you want
to take your chili lime seasoning and at
the end you want to kind of do that with
your cilantro and you end up with the
finished product just like this I know
so many people who love street corn it's
great all year round yeah for sure great
holiday idea you guys have other ideas
as well oh we do and you know we could
talk about our classic Bourbon and honey
which is Basil Hayden honey water which
is just honey and boiling water super
easy to make at home with fresh squeezed
lime lemon juice and just great for
these chilly evenings that we've had
lately anybody would love to get a gift
card from Cheesecake Factory for the
holidays and you have a great special
going on oh well soon she mentions it
right now for every fifty dollars that
you buy in our gift cards either online
or in the restaurant we're offering a 15
bonus card for you to have and use for
from January 1st to February 28th this
year so a great idea it's great to give
and receive yeah and then you can go buy
somebody dinner there you go this is
wonderful your menu is so big I always
feel like oh my gosh I don't know what
to choose what are your favorites oh
mine is the chicken Bellagio okay um so
but it's so funny since I started
working for the company what my first
favorite is not what my favorite is
currently so you guys should come and
check it around and try something
different we'd love to have you all
right Michael Don thank you thank you so
much for being here happy Holidays to
you